hello I'm Nik gowing welcome to the
emmanuel center here in London for this
intelligence squared debate on whether
the nuclear deal with Iran will or will
not make the world a safer place the
nuclear deal was reached in July between
Iran and six world powers the US UK
Germany France Russia and China Tehran
will halt its nuclear weapons program in
return sanctions that have been
crippling Iran's economy for more than a
decade will be lifted progressively so
the motion for this debate the nuclear
deal with Iran won't make the world a
safer place we have an excellent panel
for you here arguing for the motion
emilie Landau head of the arms control
and regional security program at the
Institute for national security studies
at tel aviv university in israel welcome
and Professor Alan Dershowitz one of
America's most celebrated lawyers his
latest book is the case against the Iran
deal against the motion we have Jack
Straw he was foreign secretary under
Tony Blair from 2001 to 2006 and he has
just returned from visiting Iran and
Norman Lamont Lord Lamont was UK
Chancellor of the Exchequer
under John Major in the early 1990s he's
chairman of the British Iranian Chamber
of Commerce welcome to you all well
shortly you'll be hearing from all four
panelists too for the motion to against
I will then throw the debate open to you
on the floor let's get the opening
statements now from the panelists
speaking first for the motion
dr. Emily Landau has written and
lectured extensively on the
proliferation challenges posed by Iran
dr. Landau the floor is yours
please welcome
good evening ladies and gentlemen
in remarks at the Carnegie Endowment in
Washington US Secretary of State John
Kerry said he's absolutely convinced
that the United States its allies and
the world will be safer if Iran doesn't
have and isn't anywhere near to getting
nuclear weapons I think we can all agree
to this and this is indeed what the idea
was behind the deal announced in July
but then he continued by saying that the
verification measures and the
transparency in the deal mean that the
United States will know whether or not
Iran is getting close to a weapon and
it's here where things begin to unravel
so let's take a quick look at the deal
and why it won't make the world a safer
place first it does not prevent Iran
from obtaining nuclear weapons rather
the success of this deal critically
depends on Iran upholding the terms and
not cheating now think about it it took
the international community 12 long
years to get this agreement how likely
do you think it is that they are going
to be looking for violations that might
now jeopardize this deal and if they do
focus on a violation will there really
be enough time to make and execute the
necessary decisions like is this indeed
a violation is it a significant
violation what can we do about it what
should we do about it who will do it and
how is Iran likely to react can we
really expect effective solutions in a
reasonable time frame and I want to
remind you with regard to the so-called
snapback sanctions Iran has already said
if sanctions are reimpose on Iran this
will be cause for Iran to leave the deal
in part or in whole this Iranian threat
is
worked into the text of the deal the
second reason why this deal is not going
to make the world a safer place is that
it doesn't alter Iran's motivation to go
nuclear and yet the deal will sunset
after 10 to 15 years regardless of
Iran's behavior
finally the deal works against the world
being a safer place in the third sets
indications that the deal is already
undermining the global non-proliferation
regime Saudi Arabia has made similar
statements about getting the same
nuclear rights that Iran got in the deal
this is a serious challenge for
non-proliferation efforts now having
said all this as an expert on nuclear
non-proliferation and arms control I'm
sure that there are those of you in the
audience that are viewing me primarily
as an Israeli and I'm sure some of you
at least might be thinking you know Who
am I to criticize so I want to explain
to you why I have no qualms about
supporting the motion also as an Israeli
the fact that you can attach the word
nuclear to two states does not make
those two states identical Israel has a
policy of nuclear ambiguity for over 45
years it's about keeping a low profile
it's about a record of restraint and
responsibility in the nuclear realm no
testing no nuclear threats no talking
about whatever capability Israel has
Israel is focused on one thing only in
the nuclear realm and that is to deter a
threat to its very existence
ensuring that it is not annihilated
that's it as a sovereign state Israel
made a decision back in the late 1960s
not to join the NPT and thus Israel
never made a commitment in this regard
same as India same as Pakistan and
Israel is paid a price for this decision
in terms of civilian nuclear cooperation
now let's consider a ran horrific
rhetoric directed towards the United
States and Israel hegemonic moves in the
Middle East so Iran's record in the
nuclear realm is obviously quite
problematic moreover when we consider
Iran's motivation in the nuclear realm
unlike Israel there's no basis for
assuming that Iran is purely defensively
oriented so images are one thing but we
must focus on realities on the ground
and they can be quite different from
what we sometimes assume thank you very
much
dr. emily landau speaking for the motion
the first speaker for the motion let's
get the first speaker against the motion
Jack Straw foreign secretary I'm the
British Prime Minister Tony Blair and I
should say that mr. straw led a British
parliamentary delegation to Tehran in
2014 and he's just been on a visit to
Iran checks for the floor is yours
thank you very much and good evening
ladies and gentlemen this motion is
wrong the deal between Iran and major
world powers made on the 14th of July
this year has already made the world a
safer place moreover those arguing
against the deal failed comprehensively
to come up with any credible alternative
not one word in what Emily had to say
was about the alternative to this deal
there is no better deal available this
one took 12 years of complex
negotiations and the only alternatives
are stalemate doing nothing or what I
regard is the insane notion that bombing
Iran will bring that country back to the
negotiating table and that will make the
world a safer place it won't and it
can't
Israel has legitimate security concerns
but I've always find it difficult to
accept arguments from Israel about why
other countries should accept their
obligations under the non-proliferation
treaty when Israel a nuclear-armed state
has always refused to accept any
external obligations whatever in respect
of its nuclear weapons in late 2002 it
became clear that Iran had developed
nuclear facilities which they'd failed
to disclose under the treaty and which
could have been used to develop nuclear
weapons with my French and German
counterparts I began the negotiations
with Iran to bring them into the
compliance with their treaty obligations
when the moderate president Hitomi was
in power we made considerable progress
to achieving a deal but never clinched
one President harder me who'd provide
extensive hope for the US invasion of
Afghanistan was rewarded for his efforts
by President Russia's extraordinary
decision to bracket Iran with Iraq and
North Korea as an axis of evil and when
heartily left office at the time when we
could and should have done a deal Iran
had no more than 200 centrifuges by
which to enrich uranium when the Bern
itíd appalling regime M Anna de Naja
ended in 2013 that rouhani was elected
Iran had closer to 20,000 centrifuges
sanctions against Iran tightened because
of Ahmadinejad obduracy obviously were
having an adverse effect on the Iranian
economy and its people president rouhani
judged that Iran's future lay in ending
his country's isolation and happily for
the rest of the world
President Obama judged that the only way
to resolve the standoff with Iran was by
negotiation and not war and the joint
comprehensive plan of action between
Iran the US and other world powers
agreed in July this year is one of the
most thorough such agreements ever
reached so one of the alternatives of
military strikes on Iran's nuclear
facilities elements in Israel and some
in the United States have been
threatening these for nearly a decade
if military strikes were such a
brilliant idea why weren't they used on
the Ahmadinejad regime when Iran really
was diplomatically isolated as Mayor
Duggan former head of Mossad the
external intelligence agency of Israel
has pointed out military strikes would
strengthen the hardliners in the Iranian
regime united's people against Israel
lead to a collapse an immediate collapse
of international sanctions and indeed
hasten the day when Iran did become a
nuclear weapons power such action would
also leave Israel more isolated than
ever
Israel is for sure entitled to live in
peace and security within its
internationally agreed borders
this deal provides Israeli people with
that security at a time of bloodshed
desperation and despair across much of
the Middle East this deal is the best
news there has been for years to make
the Middle East and the world a safer
place it will do that and the deal
deserves our unflinching support thank
you very much indeed
Jack's paw thank you very much indeed
let's go to our second and final speaker
for the motion Professor Alan Dershowitz
one of America's most celebrated lawyers
with high-profile clients like Patty
Hearst Leona Helmsley and OJ Simpson his
latest book is the case against the Iran
deal Alan Dershowitz the floor is yours
thank you so much and thank you
thank you for inviting me to join this
distinguished panel I am very happy to
have learned from mr. straw that he
agrees certainly that an Iranian regime
with a nuclear arsenal would not make
the world a safer place I think we have
consensus on that issue I hope that
consensus will continue mr. straw argues
that the United States should not have
called Iran
part of the axis of evil but certainly
he agrees that the United States is
correct in putting Iran on the list
indeed at the head of the list of states
that sponsor terrorism I don't think
anybody can dispute that claim and
finally I hope we will all agree that a
wealthy and powerful Iranian tyrannical
regime that today kills execute gays
dissidents Christians bajas Sunni Arabs
and others that giving them increased
power to put that kind of restriction on
their own citizens will not make the
world a better place now if we can agree
on all those propositions then I think
the debate becomes one about means
rather than ends will this deal make it
more likely or less likely that those
agreed upon goals will be achieved I
think there can be no doubt the
determination of the Iranian regime to
develop a nuclear arsenal even Iran's
former president Ruff's and Johnny one
of the more liberal presidents has
acknowledged that Iran met with the man
behind Pakistan's nuclear bomb in an
effort to secure nuclear weapons back
during the war with Iraq and this is the
same Rafsanjani who described Israel as
a one bomb state and said that if Iran
develop nuclear weapons and bomb
tel-aviv they would kill three to five
million Israelis and that would be the
end of the nation-state of the Jewish
people and even if Israel retaliated and
bomb to Iran and kill 20 million Muslims
quote the trade off would be worth it
because it would be the end of the
Jewish state and Islam would continue to
thrive nor can there be any dispute that
this deal even if fully complied with
allows Iran to break out its nuclear
weapons after a relatively short period
of time now we have to get that issue on
the table and we haven't heard from mr.
straw what he thinks this deal says
about when Iran is permitted to develop
nuclear weapons in my book the case
against the Iran deal I quote President
Obama as saying that he should be judged
quote on one thing does this deal
prevent Iran from breaking out with a
nuclear weapon for the next ten years so
in exchange for perhaps a decade during
which Iran will develop nuclear triggers
delivery systems and know-how but not an
actual bomb if it complies with the deal
in exchange for that ten-year delay what
is Iran getting Iran is getting hundreds
of millions of dollars of sanction
relief plus the ability to earn even
more without ending its support for
terrorism without ending its support for
Assad's brutal mass murder and without
ending its intrusion in other countries
and its repression execution of its own
citizens this is not the deal that
President Obama promised me when he
invited me into the Oval Office before
his last election looked me in the eye
and said Alan you know me you've known
me for a long time I don't Bluff Iran
will never be allowed to develop nuclear
weapons I don't believe in containment
I believe in prevention I don't believe
in postponement I believe in never
allowing Iran to develop nuclear weapons
but this deal crossed virtually every
one of President Obama's red lines let's
now talk about the alternatives to the
deal the alternatives to the deal are
multifold I'm not in favor of a military
strike on Iran but I'm certainly not in
favor of taking the military option off
the table which is why in my book I
proposed an alternative the United
States Congress should pass a statute
saying we take seriously Iran's
statement at the beginning of the deal
that we will never under any
circumstances acquire nuclear weapons we
take that seriously and we make that
part of the deal we authorize the
President of the United States to take
whatever action is necessary to assure
that Iran will never under any
circumstances develop nuclear weapon
so my view is the goal of the deal is to
prevent Iran from developing nuclear
weapons forever any deal that doesn't do
that makes the world a less safe place
thank you very much
professor alan dershowitz speaking for
the motion the second voice against the
motion Lord Lamont as Norman Lamont
Chancellor of the Exchequer from 1990 to
1993 and chairman of the British Iranian
Chamber of Commerce Norman Lamont the
floor is yours
mr. chairman ladies and gentlemen I too
agree that it would be highly dangerous
if Iran were to acquire a nuclear weapon
it would be enormous Lee destabilizing
and dangerous for the Middle East in my
view this is a historic deal which will
without force verifiably prevent Iran
from developing a nuclear weapon it's
the result of 20 months of intense
negotiations between Iran and the u.s.
the u.s. plus Russia plus China plus the
UK plus France plus Germany all those
governments think this is the right deal
American Republican presidential
candidates predictably disagree
so do hardliners in Iran there's a lot
of opposition in Iran and so does Prime
Minister Netanyahu but he's been
predicting that Iran was a year away
from a bomb for the last seven years
this Agreement cuts off Iran's pathway
to a nuclear weapon firstly the
plutonium route Iran's heavy-water
reactor will be filled with concrete and
unable to be used again Iran currently
has enough enriched uranium to build 10
nuclear bombs when it's reduced it won't
have enough uranium even for a single
bomb and that cap will last 15 years
what happens if Iran cheats there will
be automatic snapback of UN sanctions
any one of the six countries involved
can ensure the re-imposition of UN
sanctions and there can be no veto so
Ron will not be free to develop nuclear
weapons but UN members will be free to
use force if there is any evidence that
Iran is developing nuclear weapons
illegally Iran strongly denies that it
has a nuclear weapons program that view
is be confirmed not once but twice by
the CIA in the US National Intelligence
Estimate that concluded around abandoned
any attempts at a nuclear weapons
program well over a year ago professor
Dershowitz disagrees with the CIA
I've not professor Dershowitz his book
here
and I wondered why he was so sure the
CIA were wrong I have this book on page
37 he quotes the supreme leader of Iran
Ayatollah Khamenei urging the Iranian
military and I quote to have two nuclear
bombs ready to go off in January 2005 or
you are not Muslims I wondered what
happened to those two bombs I was
puzzled by Mr Hammond Eze statement
since he publicly denies that Iran wants
a nuclear weapon will he publicly have
said this remark attributed to him what
is the source of professor Dershowitz
quote it's a mr. jerome corsi who i
looked up on the internet and according
to wikipedia he's a conspiracy theorist
named for numerous inaccuracies
mr. Kersey mr. corces one of those who
propagated the theory that President
Obama was not an American citizen
another of his theories another of his
theories was that the United States was
funding Iran to acquire nuclear weapons
a very strange source for you to views
professor Dershowitz I agree with
professor - of its though that sincerity
is subject to proof and good words are
not enough I agree that there is a lot
wrong with Iran its hostility to Israel
it's appalling human rights record but I
doubt that that record is worse than
that of Egypt or Saudi Arabia and we
don't hear much from the West about that
the revolutionaries are growing old and
of a country to run it is a country with
significant elements of democracy it has
a large Christian population and also a
significant Jewish population the
largest but small Jewish population in
the Middle East outside Israel Iran
unfortunately has many reasons to be
distrustful of the West the coup against
dr. Moussa Dec simply because he wanted
Iran's oil for Iran rather than for the
UK our maintaining the Sheyenne power
along with the notorious Mossad
supported secretly Savitt and then there
was the help the West gave Saddam
Hussein when he invaded in Iran it's
impossible to understand the security
insecurity and the mentality of Iran
without understanding the iran-iraq war
and the fact that they lost almost as
many people in that war as we lost in
the Second World War I believe that this
deal gives us the best hope of improving
the relations with Iran we have surely
learned enough from our disastrous
actions in the past to prefer a
negotiated settlement rather than to
push us yet again into another
catastrophic war in the Middle East
northern LaVon thank you very much
indeed
the second against the motion now I'm
going to open it up in a moment and so
can we mobilize the microphones please
but before let me give you an idea of
how you were thinking when you came in
to this debate for the motion 34%
against the motion
43% 23% of you are not sure yet so
there's a lot to play for in this debate
now as you can see by the tightness of
the percentages as you came into the
room right hands up please right let me
hear from you first I am against the
motion
I believe the deal does make the world a
safer place but what I'd like to ask is
this is the nuclear deal if the nuclear
deal delivers a nuclear weapons-free
Iran but does lead to an Iran that can
strengthen its support for terrorism
that is more enabled to repress its own
people that is unable to conduct other
international misconduct on a greater
scale do both sides think that that is
still a deal worth pursuing or whether
or not that would be a deal worth
pursuing on the proposition thank you
very much indeed microphone over there
please thank you
I commend Jack Straw on his speech he
was very careful with his selection of
words inspection is paramount I'm for
this motion by the way inspection is
paramount to this deal why did Jack
Straw say a degree of inspection as
opposed to saying a complete inspection
thank you
yes there's a woman a woman there please
can we get the microphone there I
thought that Jack Straw and Norman
Lamont speech was excellent and
particularly Norman Lamont's where he
explains some of the backdrop about the
Mossad dev the Shah and the iran-iraq
war and also really at the present
situation Iran is surrounded by
countries that all have nuclear weapons
and are in a very difficult situation so
thank you thank you right let me ask you
each of the panelists to pick up their
points but alan dershowitz I got to come
to you first because we heard from
Norman Lamont that he said that
essentially some of your evidence in
your argument is provided by conspiracy
theorists who are discredited so that
discredits much of your argument well
first of all none of the arguments I
made here were those that he cited he
dug into my book and he found one quote
that you do point to and I regret having
used that source but let's discount that
for a second let's assume Ronnie didn't
say that and let's go to what mr. mr.
Lamont also said he point to the fact
that he rises wonderful country that has
so many Jews the Jews are prisoners in
Iran they all want to come out they
won't be allowed to leave yes there is a
Jewish representative in Parliament it's
a quota there are a lot of other
questions out there and you wanted to
answer one or two of them as well Jack
Straw and Lord Lamont gentlemen the back
asked about that the nuclear deal and
said would it strengthen support for
terrorism and repression internally I
don't believe so the people who are
opposed to this deal in Iran are those
who actively support terrorism and
repression and it's for Harley and the
reformist who was supporting this deal
who in my view with the backing of an
increasingly well-educated and younger
Iranian population who want to see Iran
break away from its past Allen I don't
know how many times you've been to Iran
Allen you speak with such a thing won't
let me in would you like to try to
arrange a trip and assure my safety
they let you in because you support the
regime they don't allow let me in they
just wouldn't let me out oh I'm sorry to
hear that they won't let you in but it
doesn't it does make it rather difficult
for you to claim that Iranians are
miserable when you have no basis for
that fact let me also say at least in
Iran unlike in Saudi Arabia Christians
can practice their religion we I'm
afraid to say maintain a double standard
here the gentleman over there asked me
about that levels of it I said I spoke
about a degree of inspection so you
shouldn't read too much into that the
level of inspection provided in the
joint agreement made on the 14th of July
is about the most intensive provided for
under the non-proliferation treaty and
Iran has to sign up to what's called an
Additional Protocol has to sign up to an
Additional Protocol which provides for
that intrusion inspection let me hear
from Everly the inspections are not
where they're needed according to the
NPT there's also lots of inspections the
problem is that we're dealing with a
state that has a record of deception and
violations and when you deal with that
kind of state you need to be sure that
they're not continuing to violate and to
deceive and you need inspections in
those places where Iran has not been
allowing inspections if Iran is so
innocent of any wrongdoing of any
military intentions why have they been
stonewalling the IAEA inspections for
years if there's nothing going on
that is a very selective diagnosis it is
it is it is the the agreement provides
for 24 hours around the clock inspection
of nuclear facilities there is no
country elsewhere on earth under the NPT
that has an arrangement like this I want
to hear more from inside the audience
okay right at the back please I'm for
the motion and categorically against the
deal and the reason is Iran has an
unimpeachable track record of cheating
on all of its obligations so the key to
this deal is the verification and
enforcement I think verification as
Emily Londo suggested is deeply flawed
the actual enforcement we have seen that
it hasn't worked anywhere in North Korea
or anywhere else short of the two
shining examples of Israeli universal
military strikes in Iraq in Syria and
consider the world we would live in
today have those not taken place once
people invest billions and billions of
dollars into Iran the enforcement of
those sanctions I think is a myth thank
you thank you right who's got a
microphone over here I'd like to thank
Lord Lamont for his absolutely excellent
delivery however I do wonder that is
chairman of the British Iranian Chamber
of Commerce to what extent are you
motivated by trade rather than the issue
of nuclear safety in the world that we
live in today right
people are on the last point I have no
personal financial involvement in any
way I do not believe that you encourage
Iran to become a more liberal a more
moderate regime by locking it in the
cupboard and the truth is that an
isolating the truth is that sanctions
have very much benefited the regime
benefited the Revolutionary Guards
benefit those who can cooperate with
smugglers who can get licenses the
rationing that you have inside around
all this is a product of sanctions and
sanctions very much help the hardliners
whereas I believe that trade and
investment and contact with foreigners
would have a profound influence on their
understand the reality of Iran it is one
of the most repressive regimes in the
world and giving it more money will only
empower it to become more repressive the
dissident community in Iran that I
represent that I speak to every day is
adamantly opposed to this deal because
they want to see a change of regime they
want to see a loosening up of the
oppression in Iran and they think this
deal will make their job much harder to
achieve there are other questions to you
I you know a lot of things have been
thrown out here about there being no
alternatives that the only alternative
is military force or this deal that is a
false alternative the alternative was to
negotiate a better deal you had leverage
with the sanctions and you squandered
the leverage and you know what when
there were critics of the deal in the
United States they were brushed aside
just one more word what about North
Korea do you remember all the
celebrations about the deals with North
Korea
where's North Korea today it's a nuclear
weapons state let's hear more from the
floor please right the lady here
they are very well in touch with Iran
and their information is absolutely 90%
correct you are against the motion Iran
for last 125 years never attacked any
country any neighbors how many times
brought the United Nations deal
and I'm for the nuclear deal and I'm not
suggesting that this will work but I do
like the optimism of trying to engage
with Iran rather than doing what we've
done since 1979 which in my opinion
doesn't seem to work I need to encourage
more women to stand up please as a lady
there I'm Iranian and a woman and I'm
against that promotion professor
Dershowitz I'm a little bit upset by
your comments they're very generalized
and sorry with all due respect not very
informed or coming from a place of
knowledge so but anyway this might be a
very naive question but both sides there
represent two countries that are nuclear
weapons States and is this with this all
not be a lot easier in a very naive way
if we could actually put that as a
discussion if we can just all put down
nuclear weapons
let me ask Eve the panel to respond
particularly professor Dershowitz you
had that lady from Iran who says you're
not well-informed on her country well
let me ask you how informed you are what
country
execute more people than any other
country in the world
that's Iran what country execute more
gays
that's Iran no according to recent
reports Iran has increased the level of
its executions multipled under the new
rouhani regime what country represses
descent all descent certainly when you
compare it to Saudi Arabia you're
comparing apples and bicycles Saudi
Arabia doesn't have a nuclear weapon I
think we all agreed originally that if
Iran were to develop nuclear weapons
that would be a terrible terrible thing
for the world
it began that way now we're hearing the
rest of the debate has been praising
this country I mean I think I'm hearing
about New Zealand here but I'm hearing
about Iran and we're not asking whether
New Zealand should get a nuclear weapon
we're asking whether Iran should get in
look now at Norman Lamont
well I only wanted to make a very brief
point because I was startled indeed a
little shocked when Professor - of it
said about human rights you can't
compare Saudi Arabia and Iran because
Saudi Arabia doesn't have a nuclear
weapon what's that got to do with human
rights with the nuclear umbrella that's
a pretty deadly combination either we're
concerned about human rights because
we're concerned about human rights or
we're using human rights as a political
tool and concerned about human rights
I've devoted my life to being concerned
about human rights I don't belong to
chambers of commerce I spend my time
defending human rights all over the
world
please don't question my commitment to
human rights but I do make the position
that a country with a horrible record of
human rights a horrible record of not
complying with the rule of law should
not be trusted to comply with a deal
that could make a tremendous change in
the safety of the world so yes there is
a relationship between human rights and
the ability of a country to have nuclear
weapons rights let's see more I was one
of the don't knows when I walked in and
I have to say with so many conflicting
stories it is actually very very
difficult to decide but it seems to me
if we go forward and agree with this we
have covered everything we have covered
our back our front our sides and some of
the most powerful countries in the world
have agreed to this
I think this nation should be given a
chance most people here can agree that
Iran has a terrible human rights record
with minorities women and we don't need
to keep defending that but the the fore
side keeps drawing on that and their
loss of double standards especially
since Israel too has a history of
deception and not exactly a great human
rights record so how do you think
occupied territories so how exactly do
you feel
how how do you think that continuing
this hostility can change the situation
from within Iran or improve the human
the rights of human of women of whatever
shouldn't that be a change that comes
from within thank you right let's pick
up some of those points that we made
emily landau the the problem is that
we're dealing here with nuclear issues
nuclear weapons and capabilities are a
very serious matter if a state achieves
nuclear weapons
it's basically irreversible we all hope
that there will be change in Iran the
the people that suffer the most from
this horrific regime are the Iranian
people they deserve to have a different
regime that will better represent them
and reflect their values but when we
deal with these nuclear issues and we're
dealing with them now we have to deal
with the regime that's in power and if
this regime is allowed to acquire
nuclear weapons this will create a very
very dangerous Middle East Europe United
States and it will be tremendously
detrimental to global security Dexter
all we've heard criticism from Emily and
from Professor douche of it about the
what might have been but the deal was
the best available the deal has been
agreed whether it could have been better
probably deals always can be better
especially from critics who are
observing that's the deal and I've still
have not heard any tangible alternative
from either you or professor Joseph it's
about what you would do now give him the
deal that would make the world a safer
place in the blood treat
President Obama I think said that if the
deal weren't struck they'd be within two
or three months or several months from
accepting the deal so what is the
reality and and the reality is that we
have heard nothing from the other side
that contradicts my assertion that this
is a 10-year deal
so in nine and a half years Iran will
develop nuclear weapons and I submit
that we all agree that if Iran develops
nuclear weapons that would not be good
for peace and I think we've proved
tonight by the absence of any rebuttal
on the other side that they will develop
nuclear weapons within nine and a half
years so I think they've defeated their
own argument and I urge you to vote in
favor of the proposition and against the
deal all right
the absence of rebuttal that's what
professor Dershowitz is saying that in
nine and a half years they can start
producing nuclear weapons again well
that's that that is not correct because
quite a lot of the provisions of the
treaty last for 15 years there are
several of them some of them last for 25
years and indeed there is the NPT that
kicks in even when all the provisions
have lapsed what do you need the deal if
you have the NPT I don't need the deal
if you have that if you you can't rely
on the one hand on the non-proliferation
treaty and then the other hand say that
without a deal the non-proliferation
treaty would be meaningless
you have no prescription whatsoever dr.
Darvish
for resolving this situation you
criticize that you criticize the deal
you pick you try to pick it apart not
very successfully you then say that you
don't believe in military strikes but
military strikes should not be off the
table what is it that you want all I
know is that your strategy of no deal of
denying this deal would certainly have
made the world a much less safe why
because here on would have developed
nuclear work I'll tell you well you have
a gentle air question I tell you what
would it have been a less safe place
because he won't run without
Deal would have developed nuclear
weapons because if you say yes to that
you've destroyed your entire archive
right what what why didn't you come
clean
why didn't you actually say what your
solution is because it's in your book
and what you say is that the deal should
be supplemented by the u.s. actually
taking a decision and having the
authorization that there would be a
nuclear strike on Iran if it developed a
nuclear weapon and that should be added
to that's what you say in your book why
are you not said it tonight
first of all I have said it that is a
deliberate lie go back and look at the
videotape and you will see that I said
exactly that
what I said and what Tom Friedman of the
New York Times has said is that Congress
should pass a statute saying that we
take as part of our policy that Iran has
to stand by its commitment that it will
never under any circumstances seek to
develop or obtain nuclear weapons that's
what I say in the book and then I say
that what Congress should do is should
authorize the President to take whatever
action is necessary to make sure
whatever action is necessary action is a
word startled by the reaction president
Obama has Direction President Obama has
said all options should be kept on the
table yes all of the Israeli officials
that you quote in favor of the deal have
all said that the military option must
remain on the table as a last resort
right President Obama has said that the
Prime Minister's of virtually every
country have said that and yet you
attacked me as a war monger for actually
quoting what all the leaders of the free
world including the p5 plus one have
said so yes the military option ought to
be taken kept on the table it should not
be taken off the table ever as a last
resort because yes given a choice and I
put this to you given a choice between
Iran having military weapons on the one
hand or a military attack yes I believe
that the least worst alternative is a
surgical military attack on Iran's
nuclear
if the only other alternative right okay
right all of you that are booing what
professor Dershowitz said are so
misguided because if Iran attains a
nuclear weapon war will be your the
least of your problems there will be
such destruction in the Middle East and
beyond that you are just not looking
reality
at that point it's very clear we have a
significant division up here on the
platform thank you for all your
interventions we have not resolved it
tonight but we do have clarity of the
way you here in the Emanuel Center are
thinking let me just tell you what the
result of the vote is I remind you that
the motion is that the nuclear deal with
Iran won't make the world a safer place
and before we started the debate 34%
were for the motion 43% were against the
motion
23% hadn't made up their mind
almost everyone who hadn't made up their
mind has now made up their mind only 2%
of you haven't made up your mind and it
shifted significantly towards against
there the percentage is 35% for the
motion but 63% against the motion
so I declare the motion okay in the
future
at that point can I just say thank you
very much indeed there's been a lot of
passion in this room and a lot of
difficulty in controlling it but thank
you from me Nik gowing from this
intelligence squared debate bye-bye
you